voilà un sujet intéressant c'est le
sujet de ce nouveau smartphone c'est le
shiomi millions j'ai une très très bonne
nouvelle pour vous aujourd'hui vous
allez pouvoir gagner votre chien au 1011
ça s'est super bien
pour participer c'est très facile je
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description vous cliquez vous participez
au concours et vous serez peut-être
tirés au sort pour repartir avec votre
chien ou lumineuses et ça c'est
vachement bien et rien que pour ça
laissez moi un joli pousse sur la vidéo
juste en bas je pensais juste là où on
laisse les pouces vous me laissait un
petit pouce et pourquoi pas vous abonner
pluviales poussent mieux c est comme ça
moi je suis heureux chez au mieux on l'a
déjà de boxer ya quelques jours le
smartphone est très cool ce design est
très réussi avec ce module photo vous
avez en rond dans un espèce de faux
carré dans un espèce de faux recteur en
tout cas toutes ses formes là pour moi
se marie bien c'est très sympa ça marche
bien et c'est très bien réussie de la
partie en main mais je reste quand même
assez surpris sur la stratégie par
rapport à ce modèle là je vous explique
en 2020 shiomi a révolutionné son haut
de gamme avec le 1010 me disent mes dix
pros le midi ce propos un excellent
modèle à un peu moins de 1000 euros avec
une superfice techniques en tout cas un
mot n'est que sont très complets et
cette année je suis au me revient sur le
devant de la scène en début d'année
parce que je suis en vie quand même
présents toute l'année avec beaucoup de
modèles en tout cas en début d'année ils
reviennent avec semi 11 qui est une
évolution du need is le me disent pro
était excellent en photo le milices pro
était excellent au niveau audio avec ses
deux haut parleurs sur le côté
directivité du son qui était vraiment
bien lemay 10 pro était très performant
avec le sa dragonne 865 aujourd'hui à
notre modèle qui arrivent et qui l'a
poussé c'est le cendre agon 888 qu'on
trouve dans ce modèle là et surtout mes
dix proposent aussi une très belle
proposition aux tableaux photos et cette
année j'ai omis un peu changé la donne
c'est à dire qu'ils sont arrivés avec un
million
qui est très cool et semi 11 bien qu'il
soit intéressant me frustre un petit peu
sur quelques points ici par exemple il
faut bien situer vous avez un smartphone
qui coûte 700 49 euros 90 sur la version
8 gigas de ram 128 go de stockage et 799
euros 90 sur la version 8 gigas de ram
256 go de stockage
je pense qu'en 2020 chez tommy a fait un
peu les erreurs ou des grandes villes
mais quand je dis l'erreur de sortir son
édition met dix pros dans le même temps
ce qui fait que les milices pro à
éclipser 2010 cette année dont on fait
le choix de sortir 1 millions 11
tout d'abord est plus tard une fois
qu'ils auront des précommandes qui l'on
a commencé à être vendus qui aurait eu
suffisamment 13 sur lui eh bien on
devrait retrouver un milieu pro et
peut-être même un million ultra à voir
et même s'il arrivait ce qui arrive en
france à on sait pas tout de suite parce
qu'ici on à ce qui se fait de mieux en
terme de performance
on installera gold 888 qui est
aujourd'hui en tout cas le meilleur
processeur on puisse retrouver sur
smartphone avec un score en toutou qui
est absolument pas ils regarder ça là il
se classait premier avec un score de 700
mille deux cent cinquante c'est juste
énorme
il est classé devant le maître 40 pro de
wawel est devant l'europe fauntroy il
vit ou devant le haut-pont find x2
propres il est vraiment devant est en
tout cas ça c'est super intéressant
parce qu'on voit que ce smartphone qui
est très performant alors moi je les
prie j'ai joué avec je les utilise et
j'ai regardé des films des séries que
vous assurer que le chien au 1011 marche
très bien il vraiment très performant ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'un bios pro n'ira
pas plus loin au niveau du processeur
mais par contre il pour aller plus loin
au niveau de la ram
ici vous avez 8 gigas de ram dans les
deux configurations quand on connaît la
dn2 shiomi qu'on connaît leur
fonctionnement on sait que j'ai omis
elle montrait des muscles et montrer la
fiche technique donc ici à voir leur
flagship avec uniquement ce qu'elle va
très bien uniquement 8 giga drame
je suis un peu surpris à mon avis on
devrait arriver un modèle pro avec douze
voire pourquoi pas 16 giga de ram
il ya un autre point qui me surprend
c'est toute la partie photo si vous
venez regarder ici vous avez
effectivement un triptyque avec votre
capteur principal qui se situe juste là
on va retrouver ensuite votre
ultra-grand-angle avec un champ de
vision de 123 degrés ok pourquoi pas
connaître la macro qui sont d'une toute
petite macro vous avez par action qu'il
manque quelque chose pour moi ils ont
vraiment quelque chose qui va me manquer
ici c'est un téléobjectif
je conçois pas aujourd'hui qu'on un
smartphone à 800 euros à peu près 800
euros etc ont épaté l'objectif est le
surprenant 2021 ne pas avoir ça donc ce
manque on va retrouver ici appelle un
modèle professionnel qui arrivera qui
rappelons-le ou
avec notamment un tel objectif voire
pourquoi pas deux téléobjectifs et ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on aura une
périscopique pour venir chercher le
moins dans l'image parce qu'une fois de
plus si on me elle montre les muscles
autre point qui est intéressant c'est
l'autonomie parce qu'ici on est une
batterie de 4600 milliards peroff qui
lui est pas mal mais on sait que si on
me mbia une fois de plus à bras des
fiches techniques surboosté donc même si
4 600 millions par ailleurs c'est pas
mal c'est globalement aujourd'hui je
pense pas assez pour ce modèle l'archi
au mime montrer les muscles et on le
voit notamment sur l'entrée de gamme
avec des batteries de 5000 bio peur des
matrices 6000 milles en période ici
l'idée c'est pas tout mettre une très
grosse batterie parce que derrière et si
vous avez le sens dragon 888 puis toute
optimisation logiciel qui fait que
l'autonomie sera meilleur donc pas
besoin de mettre une très très très très
très grosse batterie mais en tout cas
4600 c'est bien on tire une journée je
m'attendrais à te lire un peu plus une
journée et demie deux jours ici je tiens
pas une journée et demie de jours alors
je peux gagner en autonomie
ce qu'il faut faire si vous voulez venir
gagner au niveau de l'autonomie et bien
c'est tout simplement de venir dans
votre paramètres d'affichage
et lorsque vous allez dans votre
résolution de l'écran vous ne restez pas
en wqs des plus ça consomme un petit peu
vous passer ici en full hd plus vous
allez perdre un petit peu en qualité
bon c'est un choix à faire c'est soit
plus d'autonomie soit une meilleure
qualité et taux d'actualisation vous le
bc vous ne restez pas on s'en va tous
passer en 60 hertz parce qu'ici il ya un
truc que schumi n'a pas très bien réussi
je trouve c'est le fait que vous n'ayez
pas de taux de rafraîchissement en
adaptatif c'est ce qu'on trouve
notamment chez samsung avec sa galaxy s
21 c'est à dire que lorsque vous avez
besoin de 100 m eh bien vous monter
jusqu'à 120 hertz quand l'application a
besoin de 100 m vous êtes en verte et
lorsque vous n'avez pas besoin de 120
hertz et bien vous êtes en 90 ans est
retrouvée dans 60 hertz en fonction des
besoins de l'application est ce qui vous
permet notamment de venir économiser au
niveau de la batterie comme ça ça aurait
été plutôt bien que ce soit intégré ce
n'est pas le cas ici et la résolution de
l'écran c'est pareil vous allez pouvoir
toucher davantage en wqs des plus ce
sera au détriment de l'autonomie donc
voyez si on veut vraiment le meilleur de
l'expérience ce smartphone est bien on
est sur une journée une belle journée
mais pas une journée et demie pas de
jours donc je m'attends aussi à voir
arriver un modèle professionnel avec une
batterie plus costaud peut-être dû 5
millions période peut-être plus on verra
soyez rassurés parce qu'ici vous avez
quand même et je vous l'avais dit
lorsque j'ai fait le boxing vous êtes un
gros bloc de charge d'un filet de 55
watts vous le recharger en peu moins
d'une heure en 45 minutes à peu près ce
que je vous conseille mme au niveau de
la charge s'ils n'attendaient pas
d'arriver
0% pour dire leur changer changer vos
smartphones lorsqu'ils arrivent à 20% de
batteries bull monte jusqu'à 80 pas la
peine de le pousser beaucoup plus haut
déjà comme ça vous allez leur charge est
beaucoup plus rapidement sera très bien
et un peu plus d'une demi-heure déjà
vous aurez fait le plein et vous serez
partie pour la journée
ça c'est bien d'ailleurs je vous ai fait
une vidéo qui vous parle de l'autonomie
du rechargement de votre smartphone donc
ça c'est un pote est aussi super
intéressant maintenant il ya un autre
point je suis un peu un peu moins sur ce
smartphone c'est au niveau de la
protection au niveau de l'écran parce
qu'ici vous avez un corning gorilla
glass victime est en fait à temps et
j'ai vraiment voulu zuma fonds pouvoir
si vous le voyez juste là la regarder la
voyez là il s'est réveillé et en fait il
s'est réveillé en étant dans ma poche en
étant posé sur une table et on est
vraiment sur des micro rayures donc rien
de bien bien non plus d'écho dans là
dessus mais par contre ce qui me pose
problème c'est que voyez je suis sur un
smartphone avec la dernière protection
de corgnet qui est plutôt bien on dit
donc il est très résistant à l'avant et
à l'arrière
et pourtant les micros rayures sont là
et ça pour moi aujourd'hui ça reste
quand même malgré tout problématique
donc c'est un smartphone que je le
conseille réellement devenir protéger
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec rhinochill
parce qu'avoir un beau smartphone c'est
bien mais il faut penser à venir le
protégé ça c'est extrêmement important
alors c'est une très très bonne nouvelle
parce que c'est la première trilogie
vous propose des coques pour xiaoming
notamment pour ce chien ou mimi aux
cherry noces il vous en avait pour tous
les goûts
vous avez aussi bien des soli de suite
pour différentes marguin évidemment sur
une suite
ce sont ces cas qui viennent protéger
votre smartphone vous le mettez dans
siro but c'est sympa ça protège et en
plus c'est très joli
vous avez plein d'univers différents que
son entraîneur le croate la nba et vous
avez fortnight vous avez pour tout le
monde pour tous les goûts et ça c'est
super sympa vous avez squale est solide
suite comme ça si vous avez également
des modèles x des crashs gars qui vont
laisser apparent le dos et la phase de
votre smartphone vous pouvez venir
mettre des bacs fait derrière qui sont
des petites décorations qui vont dire
également de protéger univers league of
legends jeunes est aussi protégé de la
vente votre smartphone avec des
protections d'écran et si vous avez des
impacts screen protector qui sont très
très cool vous en avez de toute sorte
pour vraiment protéger et éviter les
déconvenues sur l'écran de votre
smartphone vous avez une remise avec mon
code qui est en bas dans la description
vous avez d'avenir cliquer pour les
découvrir et venir protéger votre xiaomi
11 dans les meilleures conditions tout
en sachant qu'elles sont en train de se
lancer actuellement chez rhino shield
pouvez vous inscrire pour cent des
premiers inscrits et surtout être
informés lorsque c'est tout beau sortir
en termes de prise en main il est plutôt
bien c'est un grand smartphone un grand
écran ainsi donc on s'attend à bien
l'utiliser un moment à demain comme bien
l'expérience logiciel j'en ai déjà parlé
on est ici sur un miroir 12 je vous ai
fait une vidéo dédiée pour vous
présenter ni wade 12 may be well
deuxième boucle vous avez pas mal de
paramètres très très intuitif notamment
un mode claire mode sont bons c'est pas
non plus parfait donc si vous voulez une
très bonne expérience logiciel là dessus
j'ai omis a bien bossé pour globalement
sinon que l'écran est plutôt de bonne
qualité on a ici un grand écran de 6,81
pouces et très grand c'est vraiment très
très très belle dalle on est ici sur une
dalle amoled la luminosité est plutôt
bonne vous pouvez également régler la
luminosité de votre mode nuit sas une
fois de plus partie logicielle donc ça
ça marche bien vous pouvez venir avoir
des schémas de couleur laissée libre
d'automatique sadorge bien si vous le
push en saturer c'est quand même un
petit peu poussif couleurs originales
s'attirer un petit peu sur l'espèce de
verdâtre un peu jaune je suis pas hyper
hyper fan moi ce que je conseille quand
même c'est l'automatique qui
fonctionnera bien et en toute
circonstance l'astucieux une fois de
plus a très bien bossé
l'expérience en 120 hertz apporte
vraiment de la fluidité pouvait bien
scrollé presque à l'infini
c'est très fluide ça marche bien ça
répond bien dont un très très beau
boulot là dessus très bel écran très
belle expérience
faisons un petit tour du côté des photos
écouter ce qu'on veut c'est quand même
plutôt bien je vous montrez vous allez
devoir tout au long de l'histoire ils
sont la caméra principale
on passe ensuite sur l' ultra grand
angle et ensuite on vient se rapprocher
la première c'est ce qu'on va voir c'est
la différence de colorimétrie entre le
capteur principal est lui très grand
angle ultra grand-angle sera un peu plus
bleu tandis que la caméra principale
sera un peu plus jeunes ça sera plus
flagrant un peu plus loin et ensuite
vous venez zoomer dans l'image il est
que vous au métro et bien forcément on
récupère du bruit ça lisse c'est normal
parce qu'ici vous n'avez pas de
téléobjectifs la caméra elle fumait pas
trop trop mauvaise elle vient lycée on
le voit notamment ici au niveau des
petits grains de pauvres c'est un poil
poussif bon ça c'est un peu la signature
xiaomi là dessus ça fera étape s'est pas
complètement dingue mais bon ça fera le
boulot la caméra de cette fille c'est
pas la meilleure que j'ai pu rencontrer
mais c'est pas non plus la plus mauvaise
on retrouve ici regardez moi sur un très
beau lac tout gelé très sympathique
l'amendé sur la caméra principale c'est
un peu jaune et non pas sur une trêve en
tant que c'est un peu plus bleue une
petite différence de colorimétrie c'est
un peu dommage
ensuite on vient
mais davantage comment ils sont la
caméra passe mal dans le capteur
principal eh bien on garde cet effet
jaune qui lui est propre
on peut faire du foie du x 122 x 10 que
vous voulez vous voyez comme d'un moment
eh bien on perd réellement en qualité et
ça c'est normal
les couleurs ne sont pas sûrs saturé il
a quelque chose de très naturel on voit
bien que ce soit les petits arbres en
eau que ce soit les nuages rien n'était
pas renié tout marche quand même plutôt
bien
voyez la différence la caméra principale
ultra grand temps que c'est beaucoup
plus bleue sur l'ultra grand temps là
quand même
on peut venir se rapprocher une fois de
plus mais bon je vous le déconseille il
faudra un modèle propre pour y arriver
caméra principale c'est bien même un
contre jour on voit bien tous les
détails au niveau des nuages autant
autour du soleil il très très très très
bonne gestion là dessus du côté logiciel
par shiomi ça fonctionne bien on voit
c'est poussif parce que ici au niveau de
la voiture et là je vais récupérer du
bruit donc on voit qu élément par
élément l'algorithme vient tout corriger
un petit bonhomme d'oeil ça c'est super
intéressant parce que vous voyez qu ici
on a du jaune passe on est beaucoup plus
bleue la neige et jaune
la neige est bleu on va vraiment la
différence entre kolo les deux suisses
un peu dommage dès qu'on vient zoom est
forcément récupère une fois de plus le
côté jaune mais ça marche et même à
contre jour regarder on voit bien la
neige on va tous c'est vraiment très
très bon l'algo est quand même plutôt
bien il ya un très beau boulot a été
fait par chien ont mis la dessus la
partie macron elle m'interpelle moi je
suis pas fan de la macro ou si vous avez
une caméra de 5 mégapixels je suis
vraiment pas fan mais malgré tout chà
reconnaître que xiaomi a fait du boulot
pour faire évoluer sa macro ça c'est
bien je récupère des détails et là je le
vois ici la sueur à jouer de mon fils
regarder toutes les petites que celles
de rim bien collée dessus je les ai bien
en détails donc une évolution au niveau
de la macro maintenant je ne suis pas
sûr au niveau des usages a pour moi la
macro ça reste toujours une fois de plus
un petit gadget on va se marrer là
dessus je suis pas extrêmement convaincu
pour moi ici vous avez deux capteurs qui
fonctionneront c'est votre capteur
principal ça va être votre
ultra-grand-angle pour sa faim monument
mais pour moi en tout cas ce qui est sûr
là dessus c'est que la caméra principale
sera très très bien le boulot et que
vous ne raterez quasiment aucune faute
aux conditions de lui le résultat est
plutôt pas mal au niveau des photos on
voit qu'ici au niveau de la lumière
il a un peu plus de mal mais bon voilà
c'est un peu du pont de détails
l'ultra grand-angle c'est à proscrire
vous allez voir de l'autre côté un ultra
grand temps n'est pas forcément pour
faire des photos de nuit le résultat est
assez apprécié pas extraordinaire on
peut venir zoom et un petit peu mais bon
voilà c'est pas particulièrement fait
pour ici là il me sort une espèce de
petit aberration à cause de la lumière
qui est pas complètement dingue il a un
petit peu de mal ici aussi
vous allez voir que des fois il a un
petit peu de mal avec ses lumières mais
c'est vraiment du point de réglages je
pense du point de détail luttera
grand-angle on oublie là c'est bien sauf
sa salle vallier cette partie là je ne
sais pas ce que c'est il me l'a rajouté
sur la photo parce que en réalité ça
n'existe absolument pas et une fois de
plus ultra grand-angle on oublie enfin
ya notre peau qui m'intéresse c'est la
partie audio lors la partie audio
j'avais beaucoup aimé l'année dernière
avec les chevaux mis le me disent pro
notamment parce qu'effectivement vous
avez deux haut parleurs à haut parleurs
qui se situe juste là c'est le haut
parleur de droite et l'autre par laure
lepailleur de gauche qui est juste là
qui vous permet d'avoir une vraie
expérience stéréoscopique puisque le son
sort de chaque côté de la même manière
et ici je trouve que c'est moins bien
c'est moins intéressant parce que en
réalité le sont effectivement sortir du
côté droit et du côté gauche
sensiblement de la même manière sauf que
en fait ce ne sont pas exactement les
deux mêmes hauts parleurs donc vous avez
ce fameux effet déséquilibre qu'on
retrouve beaucoup à la concurrence mais
j'avais trouvé ça vraiment bien la
dernière chez shiomi parce qu'on n'avait
pas cet effet là et que vous aviez
vraiment le son qui partait comme sa
leçon qui partait comme ça et
aujourd'hui c'est pas réellement le 4
mai d'où son enterrement
la série dallas est là pour longtemps là
on dans son entourage
bush la charge brute médiane sais pas
ben gaudin vaut il n'y a pas eu quelques
petites différences à côté de ça c'est
un smartphone quand même de la puissance
et puis surtout vous allez bien
l'utiliser pour ajouter du contenu
multimédia notamment bluetooth pourquoi
pas si vous avez un casque sans fil
c'est un smartphone que je trouve super
actuelle vous avez aujourd'hui quasiment
ce qui se fait de mieux je vous le dis
bluetooth 5.2 vous avez du wi fi sync et
du nfc pour le paiement dématérialisé
ici vous n'avez pas d'extension de
cartes mémoire vous avez effectivement
une double sim mais ici vous n'avez
absolument pas la possibilité de venir
mettre une carte micro sd en extension
on voit qu'effectivement les
constructeurs ont fait de plus en plus
le choix de supprimer ces extensions de
carte micro sd simplement pour vendre
des abonnements claude allez savoir
et je passe le bonjour à philly qui m'a
posé la question directement sur
instagram donc voilà ici tu vois on peut
permettre des cartes sd malheureusement
côté tarifs comme gold et on est à 750
euros 7 149 90 pour la version 828 et 7
199 90 points 800 euros pour la version
8 256 ailleurs s'il vous intéresse mais
les liens madar la description massa
smartphones que je trouve intéressant
que je trouve bien mais je vous dirais
d'attendre peut-être un tout petit peu
pas pour vous dire ne l'achetez pas
parce que le smartphone je trouve bien
et bien réussi intéressant mais pour
voir ce qui va arriver avec le million
ce pro je suis sûr que le million ce pro
et le million ultras ne vont pas tarder
à arriver
donc si vous voulez un très bon
smartphone avec beaucoup de performances
avec un bel écran le million si
maintenant expérience photo est très
importante pour vous de vous mais aller
beaucoup plus loin et notamment au
travers d'un téléobjectif et vous voulez
smartphone très polyvalent de ce côté là
eh bien je pense que ça vaut le coup
d'attendre encore quelques jours pour
voir ce qui va arriver du côté de chez
chuo me avec un million ce pro et
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas aller savoir
un million ultras qui pourrait peut-être
arrivé en france ça serait une super
nouvelle
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez que
vous trouvez que pour 750 euros 800
euros il manque quelques petites choses
au niveau de la photo est ce que vous
trouvez que l'autonomie est suffisante
pour ce tarif là est ce que vous le
trouvez que le produit est chouette est
ce qu'il pourrait vous satisfaire mark
et moi tout ça bien évidemment en bas en
commentaire maintenant je trouve
extrêmement vite pour continuer bien
évidemment a parlé de tirs au but par
les textes parce qu'un plein c'est à
dire et ça c'est cool et je vous invite
à venir écouter le podcast fréquence
bredan qu'elle interviewe pierre alaux
warcq et le directeur marketing de
chiots millions parc b
évidemment de ce million et de la marque
comprendre le positionnement l'évolution
tout ça tout ça c'est super intéressant
et d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas participer
au concours pour gagner votre chien au
1011 pour participer c'est facile vous
avez le lien en bas de la description
vous participez au jeu vous vous
inscrirez et vous serez contacté si vous
êtes tirés au sort ça c'est plutôt une
très très bonne nouvelle
merci xiaomi du cadeau merci monsieur
beauchamp brasse beaucoup d'amour et à
très vite
ciao